well if you can't take the drama then
you shouldn't even be in a relationship
rory gilmore was america's sweetheart
until
she wasn't she was everything we wanted
to be from determined to studious to
kind-hearted
throughout gilmore girls and a year in
the life she steadily becomes less
involved with her studies and her
journalism career
and her character arc takes a downward
spin it's her first love
it'll probably yeah
i know in the first season of gilmore
girls we meet rory
as a rosy cheeked bright girl with an
even brighter future ahead of her
but by the revival series a year in the
life her character development was more
or less tossed aside
we watch rory gilmore fall from grace
what happened
why the pilot episode shows her getting
into a prestigious private high school
chilton because of her excellent grades
and writing prowess
it's clear that she's on track to
accomplish her dream of becoming a
renowned journalist
although she faces some challenges she
overcomes them with relative ease
like when she gets a d grade on her
first chilton paper learn from your
mistakes
and later arrives late to the test
rendering her unable to take it
she bounces back i was up all night
studying and then i missed my bus
so i had to drive by the end of the year
she ends up in the top three percent of
her class
and by the end of season three she gets
into three different ivy league colleges
in season four rory starts at yale her
first year of college is an adventure
and she learns that she can't handle the
same course load that her grandfather
had when he attended the prestigious
school
but she still comes out strong on her
path to becoming a journalist
as we watch season five we start to see
rory slip in a major way
she takes on an internship with mitchum
hunsberger a newspaper big shot
it's very nice but very unnecessary it's
her first taste of the journalism
industry which exhilarates her
although her confidence tells her she's
doing a good job hitting her stride
her world falls apart when mitchum sits
her down and tells her she doesn't have
it where it is whatever it takes to be a
great journalist
i just don't think you really have the
drive to put yourself out there to be
honest
for the first time in her life rory
doubts her path and she heads into a
tailspin
because of mitchum's criticism rory
steals a boat with her boyfriend logan
let's go huntsburger let's go landing
her in jail
and she eventually makes the decision to
drop out of yale crime and dropping out
of school
would have never occurred to season one
rory this huge shift
shows how far she has fallen from who
she originally was to season six rory
leaving school makes sense her logic is
if she's not going to be an amazing
journalist like she always planned
why go to school at all this mentality
lasts most of season 6
but she does make the decision to go
back to school she rises above mitchum's
harsh words and gets back on her path to
becoming a journalist
the final season comes and with it comes
rory's graduation from college
at first it appears that she has no
prospects she rejects logan's marriage
proposal
and she has no leads on a job or so it
seems
in the final minutes of the show rory
gets a job following obama's campaign
trail as a political journalist
the ending of the show leads us to
believe that rory is still on her path
to achieving greatness in her chosen
career path
congratulations that's great news thank
you yeah i'm really excited
ever since gilmore girls ended in 2007
fans have been clamoring for more of the
dynamic pair
lorelei and rory our wishes finally came
true in 2016
when netflix aired a year in the life a
revival series of the beloved show
there was a lot riding on this for fans
and many feel as though it did not
deliver
especially on rory's character arc we
expected to see rory rocking the world
of journalism
the revival starts off on a good note
when we learn that rory's work was
published in the new yorker
but then we find out she's rootless as
she says in the first episode winter
this is my time to be rootless
throughout the revival
rory tries and fails numerous times to
get a desirable job that suits her
she even gets rejected from a job where
she was a shoe-in
later when she gets a job offer at
chilton we think that maybe she'll give
up her dream and instead pursue teaching
but when she rejects that we're led to
believe that rory is still on track to
becoming a journalist
after all that's what her story's always
been about despite whatever challenges
she faced
she's always able to overcome them so
that she could one day
accomplish her dream that's one of the
reasons we love rory so
much her consistent failure met by none
of the overcoming tenacity we see in the
original series
is disheartening to watch matters are
made worse
when we're introduced to the tangled web
that is her love life
instead of having a steady boyfriend or
being a strong independent woman
she plays the other woman to her
ex-boyfriend logan hunsberger
a man who hasn't changed a bit since the
series ended nearly 10 years earlier
you deserve that i do i do deserve that
it's
also worth mentioning that throughout
the revival he is engaged to another
woman
watching logan and rory act like
careless teenagers when they're in their
30s
was hard to watch to say the least by
the end of the series we expect to see
rory in a job she loves or maybe on her
way to a job she loves
but our expectations are not met as far
as having a career go
she has more or less given up on the
search instead
she's decided to write a book what it's
a cool story
it's got a point of view and it's
something only you can write and she
finds that the perfect place to do so
will be in her grandparents house
specifically her late grandfather's
study the book of course will be titled
gilmore girls
at the very least she's writing and if
we know anything of her skill
it will be a best-seller if she can get
it published
that is many fans feel that this was a
cop-out and overdone
in television shows additionally rather
than telling her mother about a new job
or career
prospect she ends up telling lorelei
that she's pregnant
mom yeah
i'm pregnant we never find out who the
father is because the series abruptly
ends there
this sudden end and lack of information
rub fans the wrong way
thanks to the revival it seems that
rory's potential is completely wasted
the series could have shown rory rising
above all her failures and ending up in
the place where she's meant to be but
instead
it shows her galavanting through life
with her ex-boyfriend and
taking life with reckless abandon the
revival is so close to exemplifying all
the things we love about rory
but instead it backtracks on her
character development leaving us all
unsatisfied
i'm just mad about the boy ah yes
we want to know why this all happened
first
we want to know why rory didn't end up
with the journalism job of her dreams
second we want to know who the father of
rory's baby is
and why the creators chose to end the
revival with those four fateful words
according to amy sherman palladino the
show's creator
rory's inability to get a job in the
field of journalism is not a reflection
of rory or her skills
it's actually a reflection of the
industry we wanted to say that she
unfortunately picked the exact wrong
time to pick this career choice
and reflect a little of what's going on
in the world with journalism
said sherman palladino in an interview
with hollywood reporter
as far as the pregnancy goes the
father's identity isn't important
in sherman palladino's own words it was
about the event
that doesn't exactly scratch the itch
that fans have had about the father
furthermore the revival ends with rory
getting pregnant
because sherman palladino felt that it
was only right for rory to follow in
lorelei's footsteps
after all the lyrics for the show's
theme say where you lead
i will follow i want to do this so badly
i'm exhausted but is there hope for the
future
german palladino hasn't ruled out a
second revival
in a tv line article she said i really
do believe that if the time is right and
the girls are where they need to be in
their lives
it could happen perhaps at that time
they could right the wrongs of rory's
character arc
and show her rising above the challenges
that the revival laid out for her
no i'm not going through a bad stretch
fans of gilmore girls
fell in love with rory's intelligence
her determination and the way she's
always set herself on course to be a
successful journalist
she had some slip ups in the later
seasons of the show but she always
bounced back
and when we left her she was set to be a
journalist just like she dreamed
the revival disappointed fans with no
career prospects and a surprise
pregnancy
but perhaps someday in the future a
second revival could write the wrongs of
rory gilmore's character arcs
there are no definites in this world as
made clear by the revival
but there's always hope